well folks it is starting Donald Trump
hid a 19.8 million dollar loan from a
North Korea linked company while he was
President very quickly paid that off
never disclosed it and the questions are
growing and growing and growing a number
of important and detailed articles to
look at including a Forbes article
called Trump owed hidden debt while in
office this is clearly only the very
beginning and remember
his tax returns haven't even leaked yet
the house Ways and Means Committee has
them but they have not yet even leaked
let's dig into this first story uh
Donald Trump's business attracted so
much scrutiny during his time in office
that it would be easy to conclude that
all the information about its foreign
entanglements would be out by now but
it's not buried in a heap of recently
released financial paperwork sits a
surprising Revelation Donald Trump had a
foreign creditor he failed to disclose
while running for president in 2016 and
after assuming office in 2017. the
documents compiled by the Trump
organization and obtained by the New
York attorney general show a previously
unreported liability of 19.8 million
dollars listed as LP Daewoo
the debt stems from an agreement Trump
struck to share some of his licensing
fees with Daewoo which is a South Korean
conglomerate that partnered with Trump
on a project near the UN headquarters in
New York City
Trump eliminated the debt five and a
half months into his tenure as president
according to the documents he seems to
have acted with urgency to wipe the
liability off his balance sheet from
2011 to 2016 the balance stayed static
at 19.8 million paperwork capturing
Trump's Financial picture as of June 30
2017 five months into his presidency
appear to show the balance dropped to
4.3 million Trump got rid of the debt
altogether shortly after that Daewoo was
bought out of its position on July 5
2017. doesn't say who paid off the loan
although the debt appeared on the Trump
organization's internal paperwork it did
not show up on Trump's public Financial
disclosure report
documents he was required to submit to
Federal officials while running for
president and after taking office
Trump's former CFO Alan weisselberg told
the New York Times in 2016 his boss
disclosed all debt connected to
companies in which Trump held a 100
stake on the documents that was not true
it's also important to understand that
there is a North Korean connection here
although it is not necessarily the most
important or titillating aspect of this
the very same Forbes article reads
there's little doubt that if the Work
World had known about the debt while
Trump was President it would have
sparked conflict of interest concerns
perhaps heightened by daewoo's
historical ties to North Korea in the
mid-1990s The Firm was the only South
Korean company permitted to operate a
business inside North Korea most people
as Rich As Trump would not be heavily
influenced by a 20 million dollar loan
regardless the fact that Trump managed
to keep the debt secret for so long
underscores how weak the government's
ethics safeguards are how difficult they
are to strengthen and how easily Trump
could Barrel right through them as he
runs for president again in
2024. so there are a few issues here
I would say that there are four issues
here number one
is this also still just the tip of the
iceberg this has been a question as far
as Trump's taxes go now for more than
five years what we what we know is
already really bad and every time we
learn a little bit more
we are brought inevitably to the
question of how much more is there that
we don't even know about is this that's
issue number one issue number two
this was hidden
that this was deliberately hidden and uh
that is a problem number three the
sudden rapid payoff of the debt while
having made no progress on the debt for
a very long period of time what was the
reason for the apparent sense of urgency
it would be important to learn about
that and then number four I maybe I
skipped I don't know number four the
North Korea connection and is it
possible that this might have influenced
in some way Donald Trump's Obsession
quite frankly with uh Kim Jong-un and
North Korea and the meetings and the
handshakes and all of that stuff again
as the article says normally someone
this Rich isn't going to alter their
behavior dramatically over 20 million
but we have good reason to suspect
Trump's not actually as rich as he
claims to be
and also because it was hidden it only
raises the alarm around that as well the
uh by the way it is continuing to to
stun and uh uh you know shock that the
obsession from the right
is with Hunter Biden's laptop and
references they claim are to Joe Biden
for which there is no proof and
meanwhile we have all of this actual
proof and financial records where there
is not even a doubt that it's all about
Trump Trump's name is on all of it
refuses to release his tax returns we
figure out he owes money to South Korea
it's a North Korean link company he hit
it uh and then you've got examples Saudi
Arabia Russia China all these different
things
we have to look at what might be but
there is no evidence has anything to do
with Joe Biden in documents it is
continued hypocrisy this is almost
certainly only the tip of the iceberg
and indeed if those tax returns ever
leak
I'm not saying leak them to anyone I'm
just saying if they leak
I would expect way more of exactly this
type of stuff our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo never
from trees meaning no deforestation
sustainability and climate change can be
a tricky topic for people of all ages it
can be particularly challenging to talk
about with kids and real paper recently
launched the little lemurs box a 24 pack
of their bamboo toilet paper with a
beautifully Illustrated Kids book that
tells an exciting story of
sustainability the box is designed to
spark creativity and kids create an
opportunity to talk about deforestation
plastic pollution in a way that's light
and easy and with the holidays here the
book makes a great gift for a little one
on your list real papers little lemurs
box and all of the other products are
available in Easy hassle-free
subscriptions or just simple one-time
purchases on their website all orders
are conveniently delivered to your door
with free shipping and this is the best
part 100 recyclable plastic free
packaging go to realpaper.com
lemur and sign up for a subscription
using Code Pacman at checkout to get 30
off your first order and free shipping
the link is down below